what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time sorry
while wall street's trying to get rich
i'm good the rest of us is trying to get
our lunch money right polina might fall
off the chair who knows who cares well i
care
duh of course i'm just an angel i better
care and i do care of course because i'm
an angel
uh lunch money is now sponsored by block
five block five has three products you
can buy and sell crypto you can deposit
crypto
and get us along get your crypto
collateral or
you can use my favorite product which is
the interest bearing account go to
blockfly.compomblock5.com
pomp what's up what's up guys we're in
miami
what up if you see us say what's up
okay nobody's gonna see us that's right
because i ain't leaving
i ain't leaving my apartment let's go i
was just
airbnb whatever this is called i was
just out on the balcony it's very nice
it's sunny i've seen the sun
i hate the snow i hate the cold i have
seen the sun see
okay what's up so yesterday four people
died and dozens more were injured amid
amid the riots of the us capital police
said after supporters of president
donald trump invaded the building to
prevent the confirmation
of joe biden's electoral victory
do you want me to say what i believe why
not
do you as the people want to hear my
opinion
what's your opinion i think
that this is just as bad as when i was
saying that the riots
around the social justice issues was
just as bad
violence and this nonsense
is unacceptable point being period i
don't care what your reason
for breaking into government buildings
is you shouldn't do it
i don't care if it's literally because
of uh aliens showed up
if it's because of social justice issues
it's because of an election
whatever there are ways to protest
and do it peacefully and then there are
nonsense this is nonsense point blank
period that's fine
um i saw this video of this woman
like being like i got maced because i
was trying to enter the capitol
it's like what did you think they were
gonna roll out the red carpet for you
i'm shocked i'm shocked
that there wasn't a bigger law
enforcement military response
yeah same i i'm just really
sad about everything what
uh i just love america and i hate seeing
it like this i hate the guy in the
viking costume i hate the guy in the
bear hat i don't like seeing any of that
violence and
[Music]
protesting is one of the most american
things that you can do
but being a loser
in a bear hat just makes you a loser
wait can you talk about the elon musk
tweet
elon musk had a great meme it may be the
meme of the year
we are only only a couple of days into
2021
and i think elon musk may steal meme of
the year already
it is a domino so this has got a really
small domino and the bigger bigger
bigger bigger bigger
all the way up and then it's like a
massive domino at the end and in the
front
it's a guy he's about to knock over the
first domino and obviously it's they're
all going to fall over
and in the front where he's about to
knock it over it just says website
to rank girls on campus
and then in the back it says there is a
man
in a viking hat who now has control of
the capitol building
and he's basically just like hey you
start out with a hot or not type website
and next thing you know you there's you
know the unraveling of american
democrats
by the way i don't think that the social
media platforms are to blame for this
stuff
what's really concerning think about
this this is this
is nuts the american
leader of the free world he's still the
president of the united states
yesterday was censored
by social media platforms well i don't
want to live in a world
regardless of which side of the
political aisle regardless of what
they're saying
i do not want to live in a world so your
position is where you see
all the everything that is said i don't
want to live in a world
where facebook twitter google etc
or deciding what is true and what is
next okay the problem is the problem is
that
when they do that uh you may be able to
think for yourself there's people who
are like
oh we should go storm the capitol
building
again the reason why we have
the media is because they have a
journalistic process
that process goes through fact checking
interviews sourcing editing
etc the technology companies are not
set up to make decisions on what is true
or not true i will give you a perfect
example
back in march there was a conversation
around where the virus could have come
from and if you remember
zerohedge was kicked off the platform
for saying that it was
possible that it came from a lab in
china
now being reported in the washington
post new york times
and other places there are lots of
reports of people saying
that is probably the most likely place
it came from
the social media platforms are in a
lose-lose situation if they do nothing
they're going to get yelled at
if they do something they're going to
get yelled at and therefore
i think it is important for us to
recognize as a society
the technology companies do not have the
resources necessary
to decide what is true and what is not
and so it's great
when they're making decisions on things
you disagree with you're like this is
awesome
but then when they go to do it again
something that you agree with you can't
then
complain and so rather than get on the
slippery slope
my whole opinion is by the way i think
yesterday was absolutely insane
and it's not acceptable but i do not
think we want to live in a world
where the technology platforms are
making decisions there's a lot of
layers to peel back here we're not going
to do it in a 20-minute show
all right um the dao ra
yesterday while all this nonsense is
happening stocks hit an all-time high
how is this possible i wrote about it
this morning oh
the dao and the nasdaq all-time highs
bitcoin all-time high why
because the market is being manipulated
how is the market being manipulated
the central banks they're just pumping
money in they're literally just pumping
asset prices
it doesn't matter armageddon could
happen tomorrow and the stock market hit
an all-time high
not because the stock market's becoming
more valuable it's literally just
because they're
that it's blowing hot air it's just
blowing hot air into the economy
so that asset prices continue to inflate
you see that hot air
inflate see do you guys see me out here
do you see me
elon musk just became the richest person
in the world
with a net worth of more than a hundred
and eight
billion dollars 84. sorry 85
80 45 yeah 185 billion uh
wait wait this is completely wrong
literally same article two separate
sentences oh maybe cnbc is not equipped
to figure out the truth
is it 84 is it 85 i don't know um
so so i also saw that
the the people who shorted uh the tesla
stock like lost like 40 billion dollars
or something crazy
i can't find it now but losers
anyway so if you were short in tesla you
were wrong the market's a referee by the
way elon must be the richest guy in the
world after he posted that meme
yesterday
is all time like i love elon musk
not only because he's an innovator but
because he literally does not care he's
gonna post whatever memes he wants to
post
and if you want to be a billionaire and
a meme lord go right ahead elon go right
ahead so
we gotta go through this because you're
gonna yell i got six minutes yeah okay
but you but but but i just want to
congratulate you on wearing the uniform
today
and i wanted to say that you look very
uh stunning
which might be the word some would use
if you think plin is beautiful and smart
you should leave a comment you don't
need to hear it
roblox the kids online gaming company
said they
raised 520 million dollars in a private
financing round
and announced separately that it will
soon go public through a direct
listing wow what do you think
i think roblox is one of like the most
underrated companies
it's kids love it their parents love
it and it's getting bigger and bigger
guys take a look
roblox r-o-b-l-o-x yeah
we're not running free ads here uh-uh
you want me to talk about roadblocks you
better pay me
you guys got 520 million dollars the
thing is that roblox was first released
in 2006.
wow that's a long time overnight success
15-year overnight success all right
final story of the day fortnite
developer epic games
just bought a north carolina mall for
its new headquarters it's where you're
from right cary north carolina
yeah they bought the local mall epic
games is in carry north carolina it's
the city i grew up in the town i grew up
in and
uh they bought the kerry town center
which is literally the mall
when we were when we were kids we used
to go
like we're gonna go to the mall that's
the mall we would go to me and my
brothers be running around
like little savages trying to figure out
how we're going to convince my mom to
buy us auntie anne's
and uh what we ended up realizing is
that the mall basically died like it's
not a dying it's literally done
wow like when i was home for christmas
uh joseph and i my brother joseph and i
we went to that mosque where
uh i got my dad's uh christmas gift from
and
it's a ghost town wow well it's about to
be epic's headquarters
is it is underrated
how big this thing is like it is a mask
i said like three stories
[Music]
the department stores have multiple
stories but the middle is the thing but
like even like the parking lot
it's like probably 20 acres of land if
not more
that they have plus they've got this
whole like
i don't know what they're gonna do there
it would not stop it'd be awesome if
they built the esports arena though that
would be
so sick all right ready yes hello
uh dodo 24 oh it's ass launchment i
always forget uh
hashtag asklm in the comments dodo24116
says
hello pumpkin pimp let's say tomorrow
you're put in charge of the federal
reserve what would be your five-year
plan to correct the
damage done by said federal reserve
what do you think i think i'd take all
the money in the treasury
and hand it out to all the people in
america
oh well that's what they're doing
anyways they're doing it they're just
giving away the money for free just like
helicopter money
so they're doing i would i would like
personally hand it out to all
300 million americans you would like
walk down the street like 20 for you
20 for you 100 for you 20 million for
you yeah and then you go on the subway
be like how much you want how much
exactly exactly would you throw it like
at the strip club no
that's my plan all right you make it
rain no
okay you
controversial comment i'd rip the
band-aid off
you wouldn't pay anybody no i would walk
in
and the first thing i would say is we're
not coming to save you
period we're not bailing out any
companies
banks we're not bailing out any people
what we're here to do is we're going to
get
a financial system that's going to be
long-term sustainable by the way that
means that there's potential short-term
pain
and what we are going to do in the
meantime is we are going to help you
by not inflating away our currency
instead what we're going to do is we're
going to educate you we're going to get
you opportunities and we're going to go
build a strong financial system
that is built on something other than
intervention and there is going to be
short-term pain but as the americans
we're going to all have to buy into this
thing because if we continue down the
path we're going
we will lose global reserve status and
there is going to be
absolute destruction in our country i
don't know if that happens in 10 years
20 years or 30 years but at some point
you got to rip the band-aid off
that's what i would do i got to think
more about the exact details of how to
do it
but that's generally what i would try to
do cool and final
uh thing is not a question it's just a
shout out to rick randazzo
uh he said almost 200th episode really
like the show
been watching since march i don't think
i've missed any
thank you rick you're the best rick
randazzo
you haven't missed any wow like i've
barely you know i'm surprised you've
been listening to our [ __ ] for this
long
but we appreciate you yeah no worries
hey kids
hope you guys have a great day rick's
the man and you can be too
if you listen to your parents if you
make your bed you clean up after
yourself
and you get educated oh my god see you
tomorrow
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click
on i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risks
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends